what can you tell us about the man
behind the scenes speak of this
gentleman a big Mark Wahlberg is the
perfect human being it's 2:30 in the
morning he works out at 2:30 2:30 does a
work out goes through any sort of
scripts he has to work on he rides
around as a neighborhood he saves cats
out of trees he does more before 7 a.m.
then most people do in a lifetime and
he's constantly working out sculpting
his body to perfection occasionally yes
I'm the only one the role that I'm
preparing for requires that I would
rather be enjoying a few cold beverages
and eating some food but right now yes
I'm on bird food Patrol right
fortunately right now have you noticed
because this is the first time that you
and Mark have work together is that
right it's the first time yeah and it
was a great experience but I did notice
what you're talking about
I walked down it was blizzard conditions
this is this is in Boston in western
Massachusetts yeah it's snow and stuff
and he's out there in a t-shirt
whacking golf balls right into the snow
with a 6-iron and they're disappearing
it was so cold and there was so much
snow his balls were orange it was
terrible but and they're all perfect
shots they're all perfect shot doesn't
miss it yeah what is this all about
there's a compulsion of yours you have
to hit golf balls every day no matter
what if it's snowing and I do I tried to
hit a hundred balls a day when I workout
in the morning then I do my reading
writing I do a lot of prayer time for
will play 18 holes about 6:30 and then
I'm home and help my wife with the kids
got a lot to do before you seem a little
bitter about it so I got a lot to do oh
yeah you know what I got time to screw
around it's past my bedtime right if I
wake up at 8 a.m.
have a nice bowel movement go right back
to that
that's the way it's done yeah hey I'd do
that too but I don't get out of bed yeah
you do that in bed I got it
take care of business
you